hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote webinar titled diversity equity
and inclusion and cancer research the
promise of stakeholder engagement
this webinar is part of the cancer
research and oncology 2021 event i'm
christina todd of labyrinths and i'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots now let's get started before
we begin i would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to first participate by
communicating with the other attendees
using our new live chat feature during
the presentation you can find the live
chat located at the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker nadine
barrett assistant professor family at
family medicine community health
director at center for equity and
research at duke clinical translational
science institute and associate director
at equity and stakeholder strategy at
duke cancers institute
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
dr barrett you may now begin your
presentation
wonderful and thank you so much
christina i really appreciate that and i
certainly appreciate all those who are
part of this incredible conference over
the past two days all the work that's
gone into this and most certainly being
invited to give this talk today and to
kind of share a little bit around uh our
opportunities that we can think about
and potentially incorporate in our work
as we think about increasing diversity
in clinical trials um as i said one of
my key areas and interest is always
thinking about how do we
work toward increasing diversity in
clinical trials
and it really happens that she goes way
back for us to start thinking about what
that looks like and so today we're going
to really just go through um a session a
talk if you will it's part of a training
that i call just ask and halfway through
this session you'll understand why i
call it that um but it is an opportunity
so hopefully you'll be able to build
some strategies or ideas or
thoughts that you can actually go back
and brainstorm with your research teams
to start thinking about how you can work
toward increasing clinical research and
clinical trials
so that being said again i have um great
excitement for all of those who are
doing this great work and hopefully as
we think about the work that we're doing
as researchers in the cancer and
oncology space that we can really start
thinking about how do we work toward
engaging ourselves our teams um and our
collaborators in this work together to
become more intentional in increasing
diversity in our trials and what does
that look like what do we need to do to
be able to be most effective so again
thank you and i'm looking forward to it
now
a key part of this christina mentioned
earlier as well just so you know that
part of this talk is actually also
interactive it's in fact quite
interactive so i always encourage people
to use the chat um i may ask questions
and as i ask those questions i would
love for you to be able to put your
thoughts and your comments in the chat i
can see them and actually be able to
respond to those as well
i'll add some thoughts around that space
and so as we go throughout this
afternoon i'm looking forward to having
you all share your thoughts and your
perspectives in that space as well
so when we think about diversity uh and
we've asked the question what does
diversity look like we can look at this
picture here and you could even start
writing in the chat if you so choose to
start thinking about what kind of
diversity do you actually see here and
i'll give you all a second to kind of
think about that uh because it's really
important as we think about increasing
diversity to the intro first we know
what we're talking about and what we're
referring to when we say diversity so
feel free to put it in the chat as you
go along um
key to that is really thinking about um
all these pictures and what do we see
and so some of you may say race you see
differences in race maybe ethnicity and
certainly age is a part of that as well
so you can see some of the pictures you
have younger people people who um maybe
older and even senior citizens
there's also different types of
relationships that we're seeing in this
picture as well uh that we can make
assumptions about what those pictures
and those relationships may be we see
ability
uh we also see opportunities around as i
mentioned ethnicity and culture as well
uh thank you i see age gender race
perfect feel free to continue to use the
chat to see what else you see here uh
does anyone see anything some
differences maybe around culture
uh differences and on those spaces as
well
and so what we typically do when i show
this slide is that just as it's already
been highlighted uh in the chat and most
sentence you are referring to it and
look at it you'll see all different
types of perspectives right so we think
about for example um the woman in the
hijab and the second woman from the top
um and then also the women that are on
the fourth row second row down and we
can make assumptions or thoughts about
oh they must belong to a particular
culture and just because people wear a
certain attire it doesn't necessarily
mean they subscribe to all that we may
believe that that culture is but they
most certainly may be dressing that in
that way probably to be maybe to be um
culturally appropriate in that space
particularly if they're visiting certain
countries or they may actually ascribe
to many of the or most of the um beliefs
that goes with that culture and that
those cultures include your language
your beliefs
your spiritual beliefs your religious
practices all of that is a part of the
culture and the norms as well
so also oftentimes here we also see
there's relationships that could be uh
husband and wives it could be um a
family unit etc and i always look at
this picture and depending on what
audience i'm speaking to who i'm
engaging with uh there are oftentimes if
you look on the top row and it's about
one two the fourth picture in and you
see the three women that are there kind
of in together and one of them is in the
color yellow
and so when i ask the question around
diversity people oftentimes will say
that this picture looks like maybe a
mother and her two daughters or three
sisters and in some cases some people
actually look at the picture and say
actually that looks like a mother her
daughter and maybe her daughter's
partner and her wedding day so again
depending on the perspective in our
views we can actually look at these
pictures and have our own thoughts and
perspectives around it and and and it
could very well very well be different
from someone else even though we're
looking at the exact same picture so
when we think about what diversity looks
like and as we go throughout this day
we're really talking about diversity
across the gamut diversity in age in
race and culture in sexual identity um
um we're also thinking about in the
context of religion and able-bodied in
size all those are different ways in
which are that we are diverse in our
society and we're thinking about all of
that and particularly in the context of
those who are or may very well be
marginalized or under-engaged in
research and under-engaged in health
care
so when we look at this diversity one
some of you may be familiar with this
picture here it actually came out in
national geographic many years ago but
if you look at this picture i would ask
you what's the race of the people here
who's black
who's white
who's hispanic or latin ethnicity
who's
asian it's hard to tell right and yet
when we look at this picture the idea
was that by 2050 the diversity of the
united states would look more like this
right it'll be grow it's growing more
and more and in fact now the data shows
that it's actually not by 2050 but about
2036 that we anticipate seeing this and
so when we talk about addressing race
and ethnic disparities in access to care
quality care and participating in
research in clinical trials and oncology
or any type of study for that matter we
do have to ask that question what does
race look like and how are we going to
start thinking about that as we move
forward in our work as we think about
engaging our patients uh based on who
they are uh it becomes important to
recognize uh where that fits
perfect so this is the question here i
think there's a little lag there in the
slides
um okay great so here again this is the
picture i was referring to and again in
2015 this is what
that
was looking like
and in fact the date is now starting to
say that this is probably going to be
more around 2036 so again just
highlighting the importance of that so
when we think again about the first
picture in terms of our lens and how we
see pictures or people and how we could
all have different perceptions there
likewise as we think about this and what
we may think or ascribe someone to as
being um asian or latinx or black uh
it's hard to tell when we start thinking
about that unless we find out more about
that person and what their values are
and actually how they even self-identify
but it really is important as we think
about how we're going to address health
disparities think about it and engage
our patients and our communities in a
meaningful way based on this diversity
that consistently changes
so normally if this was part of a
workshop that i do um we would actually
go through a whole process here of
looking at these pictures but typically
when we do this i actually ask questions
around what characteristics stands out
to people here in terms of who's warm
and who's competent who so they think
they will feel more comfortable engaging
in a regular daily conversation with or
in some cases seeing people um if your
car broke down in the middle of the
night in the middle of the night uh
which one of these persons if any would
you want to show up and which would you
rather not show up what kind of thoughts
we have about women who may be a
a beauty queen is the woman is in the
bottom left hand corner or the man at
the top in the black jacket and the
black shirt uh who looks like he's in a
workshop so he goes through this whole
process and people have different
perceptions and perspectives around
who's warm who's not who they think
would be most um relatable and who they
would not be and it's interesting
because we i use this exercise primarily
to help people to understand that one we
have different perspectives and
experiences and all of that plays into
our perceptions around who we think is
trustworthy and who's not who we think
is going to be able to understand what
we have to talk about when we're
providing medical care and who may not
understand or may not follow through
with the recommendations um as a
provider because of um certain
assumptions or thoughts that we may have
about that person and when we go through
this exercise it's really an incredible
one uh where people get to get us get a
sense of that
so again in some of these cases are some
of these persons here are actually not
what most people would think that they
are uh um and that helps us to stop
thinking about how we ascribe certain
perspectives or thoughts or or
characteristics to people that may not
necessarily always fit
and so all of these factors whether
we're looking at a picture of women who
we think are sisters or our mother and
daughter and yet they may actually be a
lesbian couple getting married whether
we're looking at the diversity in terms
of what we see as race and ethnicity and
how we ascribe certain characteristics
like the color of the complexion of
one's skin uh to a certain race uh the
way in which someone's eyes may be
shaped or their hair the cotton the
texture of their hair all of those are
different ways that we make assumptions
or we in our mind start to think about
who is from what race what group what
what population and then also start to
think about what characteristics will
connect to that and what happens is in
this process is that we all if we're all
in a room today we would see that they
may be they will be very different we
would all have very different
perspectives along those lines uh it
happens every single time i've given
this talk whether the audience is 300 a
thousand or 20 people it always shows
that we have different views and it's
shaped by multiple things including the
media including one how we were raised
where we grew up um in some cases i
could be teaching with students and they
actually have never this is their first
time now as undergrads for example
actually being around a population that
is different from their own um as we
know in the united states the most
segregated time in the united states is
actually between the hours of 9 00 a.m
and 2 p.m on sundays uh that is our most
segregated time and that's usually when
people are worshiping which they
typically worship with people who look
like them
and so all of these then mean that when
we think about and we have these
perspectives um that are shaped by all
these different factors from the moment
we're born until whatever age we are now
we've been socialized to think about
groups in in different ways based on our
experiences and so that leads to our
perceptions that could actually lead to
what we oftentimes call blind spots and
so i'm going to show a quick video to
kind of give us a sense of what that is
and then we'll move forward into the
rest of the session
are you seriously considering her as a
candidate just don't trust she's a woman
that's just clearly not educated she
didn't speak english that's not me i'm
not like that
you call it an honest mistake
science calls our blind spot
our unconscious mind is a mysterious and
powerful thing it makes ninety percent
of our decisions without us even knowing
it our brains are overloaded with 11
million pieces of information every
second yet we can only process about 40
of them
so we're wired to make cognitive
shortcuts using past experiences to make
assumptions
[Music]
and you know what happens when we assume
[Music]
our unconscious mind can put us on
autopilot determining where we sit who
we lunch with who we turn to for advice
and who we choose to offer a helping
hand living our lives with blind spots
can put us in a tunnel same point of
view same decisions same outcomes we can
find ourselves trapped in the land of
snap judgments and misconceptions we've
all been on both the giving and
receiving end of blind spots
think about it
who's talented
who's able
who can i trust
who belongs
we've all been there blind spots are
part of the human condition our choices
have consequences for us and the people
we interact with by accepting that blind
spots exist we can stop
imagine what possibilities exist if we
could do it all over again
different perspectives inclusive
relationships diverse networks
better outcomes
seeing people for who they really are
people
like you
with unlimited potential
we all have blind spots
once you accept that you have them
you can choose to do something about it
it's time to check your blind spots
and focus on what's possible
[Music]
excellent and so what we learned from
that video is really highlighting what
we've known and what we've talked about
briefly already in this um in this
conversation it's really thinking about
blind spots and how our perspectives and
our views are often shaped by the views
that we have as we see or we're exposed
to uh diverse populations or people who
may be different from ourselves who we
are who we grow up with our family etc
and so these blind spots play a part in
so many ways and so when we look at the
pictures that i showed earlier along
with this video we also know that when
patients and coming to an encounter with
a provider that usually or just not even
those patients just people in general
when we meet someone new we often within
about a 30 second to 60 seconds at the
moment within a 30 second period i've
made about 60 assumptions about that
person and those assumptions are based
on multiple things their their height
their hair and how they hold your hand
how they shake your hand how strong or
loose that may be um how much they have
where they're from in terms of their
accent as you can play a part and how
much you feel like you can lean in or
not into the conversation and all of
that plays out so we're getting all this
information and we're making decisions
about how we will interact how much we
think that person is capable of
understanding everything that we have to
say and also assumptions that we may
even make about their ability to follow
through with the regiment or the
treatment that we may be providing but
this happens again across the board so
regardless of whether we're in a public
setting we're meeting someone at a
coffee shop or we're meeting someone in
our clinic for the first time as a
patient who just heard the words you've
got cancer or we're meeting a colleague
for the first time who's knew of
starting or interviewing for a position
in all of those settings there's all
kinds of perspectives that we all have
that's based on our experiences and
these are often referred to as implicit
biases or unconscious bias and some of
you may have heard those terms before
and in this case we found that
historically there's a lot of studies of
wealth of studies that go back at least
after 40 years 40 50 years if not more
that have really highlighted how these
biases or these perceptions play out in
terms of impacting health disparities so
for example we know that doctors assume
that in in studies that have shown that
providers may assume that black or
low-income patients are less intelligent
more likely to engage in risky behaviors
and are less likely to adhere to medical
advice and so this impacts these studies
showed that it actually impacted the
kinds of um treatment that they were
offered uh the type of engagement and
conversation that they had and what that
communication looks like we also know
that there's uh differences in pain
medication prescription prescribed to
black patients compared to whites it's
also the same thing for asian patients
as well where their pain medications are
oftentimes prescribed um at a at a lower
rate compared to the white the white
counterparts
we also see a wealth of literature um
sean mueller and others have done work
looking at pregnant women who face
discrimination from health care
providers on the basis of their
ethnicity and socio-economic background
so oftentimes assumptions that a woman
may be on medicaid uh when she may not
be on medicaid or assumptions that she
cannot afford to take care of um
of her care uh and when she's trying to
get care
health care for her pregnancy and her
delivery uh we also see clearly market
women present with cardiac heart disease
symptoms for example are significantly
less likely than men to receive
diagnosis and referral and treatment
compared to others and so what we tend
to see is that a young man or a male or
female may very well show up out to the
emergency room and there's a wealth of
studies now that have shown that men get
treated differently from women when they
show up to emergency room although they
may both have symptoms of what when one
may say are the beginning of potentially
a heart attack and so what we find in
that space is that women
are more likely to be asked questions um
in the emergency room about stress
anxiety are you going through a lot of
stress uh do you have children are there
issues going on at home uh how's work
going things along those lines whereas a
man is more likely to be actually taken
in not ask those questions but are more
likely to go through the full battery of
tests and more likely to even stay
overnight and so that plays in part for
why in part for why men um although
women may have heart attacks more than
men
i'm sorry men may have heart attacks
more than women women are more likely to
die from a heart attack compared to a
man um again that's not the only reason
but that certainly plays into that and
part of that could be that if you kind
of go back and think about a man and a
woman who showed up at 60 if you could
rewind time and take them down to when
they're about two years old 12 years old
or so and they both um are kids and
they're running and the little boy falls
and we pick him up and we're like oh my
goodness what is our response we're
typically more likely to use a stronger
voice um say dust it off or not as
likely nationally to pick him up but
more likely to just dust him off and say
you're okay you're strong you've got it
whereas if the little girl falls we're
more likely to pick her up and cry
almost use a crying voice with her uh
when we're saying we're like oh poor
baby oh my goodness oh did it hurt let
me kiss it that oh and cry with her um
and so as we think about this then we're
almost teaching little boys um to not
show their feelings to not have the same
kind of um response to pain as they
expect the woman to where the young girl
when little girl were actually
encouraging her to kind of she's crying
and letting it out and kissing it better
so these are studies that have shown
this for a long time in the sociology
sociology and psychosociology field and
it really plays out in terms of how
um males and females are groomed growing
up to actually not show their feelings
and so some make the argument that when
you fast forward it forward from this
child and i just have to say this i have
been a complete culprit of it myself my
own god child his little boy was running
and i literally and i teach this all the
time and he was running and i literally
stopped when he fell and i looked for a
crack in the ground just to show him
like look how strong you are you've
actually cracked the ground wow you're
so strong so even i who have been doing
this work forever still you know has to
catch my own biases in the way that i
may be feeding into some of that so then
when you fast forward these two children
and to a point where they are now adult
and they're showing up at the emergency
room at 60 years old or so um they're
more likely to actually be seen as well
we've been telling boys and men to hold
back their feelings to not show emotion
to not show their heart and so if
they're showing up in the emergency room
especially since men typically don't
engage with the health system at the
same extent as women and over the same
time as women from the age of
adolescence forward that now they're
showing up they must be in serious pain
and so they're more likely to go through
the full battery of tests whereas women
have been kind of shown to express their
feelings and their perspectives and
their hurt uh um
in a very different kind of way over the
years and so the assumption is that the
woman must be going through some other
things and this may not necessarily be a
heart attack
that she's going through
so again this is just another example of
how these biases play out so is it a
national conspiracy then in emergency
rooms across the country that says if a
man shows up take him right there if a
woman shows up asking some questions to
see if there's a problem absolutely not
we know that there's no national
conspiracy in emergency rooms across
that country but it's interesting that
we do have a national trend in our
country around this space as it relates
to emergency women experiences and part
of that is because the socialization
that we've all been socialized uh in
different ways to think about groups to
think about male female roles uh to
think about gender race uh and
assumptions that we pay and all of that
and they play out as well as much as we
don't want them to they do play at also
in how we provide care how we interact
with people whether it be in the grocery
store or as i said before in our clinics
and so implicit bias and this
unconscious bias plays a part also as
i'll share momentarily in some studies
that have been done in the oncology
space as well within cancer
so when we think about this then i also
always think about then what are the
factors that we need to think about and
where differences lie because if we have
these blind spots as we just saw in that
video um that means that the professions
that i may have of a group or you may
have other group may be different or we
make assumptions that everyone gets the
same thing so in this case here when we
talk about the prism of difference these
are some of the social categories in
which we do different right and so when
we think about race ethnicity age
sexual orientation when we think about
religion there's so much diversity in
our in our world and across the globe
that all of these factors play a part in
our perceptions depending on how exposed
we are and are one and two where we fit
in within any of these categories right
so if we think about religion for
example i often ask people uh is this is
are we living in a country where in the
united states you can actually practice
whatever religion you believe in and
most people in the room will say
absolutely without question yes this is
the land of the free this is freedom of
religion that's what we do that's what
we're founded on all of these factors
but it's really interesting because when
we actually i start going deeper i said
well what does that look like so policy
wise absolutely but what does that look
like in practice and so we start talking
about that and what we find then of
course and we're using religion as an
example here um when when people come
and they are looking or they're working
for example and they look at their time
where they want to take time off for
religious practices it just so happens
that our christmas breaks for school
systems and even where we work
oftentimes rotates around christmas time
so in december uh
and even thanksgiving for that matter uh
we're more likely to have time off right
schools occurs during that time likewise
uh spring break it just happens to
happen right around easter which happens
to be a christian holiday uh so if
you're talking about ramadan and other
holidays that happen for people who may
be muslim jurists etc those holidays
don't typically fall within that those
times where our school system holidays
typically fall so people actually have
to take that time off sometimes it's
personal time for them to be able to
actually practice their own religion so
when when someone's maybe a christian
for example we may not necessarily
recognize that oh we're getting a
privilege in terms of when we get to
celebrate our holidays compared to
others and so again that's just one
example of how even if we have policies
it doesn't necessarily mean in practice
it really works for all people of
diverse backgrounds and experiences uh
likewise when we think about what we
value in our country right or in in our
globe um when we think about these
categories again we also can start
thinking about it in the context of um
race for example where we can say uh we
have black white um asian asian pacific
islander etc and we oftentimes can think
about and
you'll notice some changes now most
certainly but you'll often think about
you know what what group is most valued
in that space um men and women what
group is most valued
oftentimes most people in the group and
in the chat people will write uh men uh
compared to women uh others will stay
white compared to other races
and there's societal norms that actually
play out that reinforces that even when
we don't realize it ourselves uh in our
day-to-day lives and our day-to-day
experiences there's always a story of
what kind of income do we prefer right
and so we talk about the joneses i have
to be careful when i talk about the
joneses now because as we get older uh
the younger generation like who are the
joneses and what are you talking about
but so but those of you who may relate
or may remember like keeping up with the
joneses what does that mean who are the
joneses where do they live they
typically live in a very um suburban
neighborhood um or a very um urban
neighborhood downtown somewhere they
also um in the urban areas it's usually
a white car i mean i'm sorry a big house
two-car garage white picket fence all of
those things are the stories that we we
um we value uh if you look at our
commercials on television our
commercials actually still give that
kind of sense of this kind of middle
upper middle class lifestyle um as being
the one that we all should be aiming and
shooting for and so again when we look
again at all these different prisms of
difference we'll see differences in
terms of what we've been exposed to and
therefore that shapes our perspective it
shifts our attitude it shifts our biases
um i often use another example of
columbine um because what happens is
these groups become invisible so when we
talk about the school shootings that
happened many years ago and i know we
just recently had another one um over
the past couple of days but most
certainly back in the day we had a rash
of school shootings um uh particularly
when one that we remember with columbine
um as sociologists um they actually
explored to see well how is this being
depicted in our society and what we
found was
that essentially the columbine um uh
shooting for example was that in the
news and on the media and it whether it
be in the newspaper or on the radio or
television it was this constant
discussion around kids killing kids why
are kids killing kids well it wasn't
really kids killing kids it was actually
um
boys that were killing kids in school
but in the media i kept saying kids
killing kids it wasn't just boys killing
kids in school but it was actually white
boys killing kids in school right um it
wasn't just though that it was just
white boys killing kids in school it was
actually white boys who were middle
class who were killing kids in school
and so what happens when we say kids
killing kids versus if it was for
example um
african american not next or if it was
women white women they would actually be
called out and said what is it happening
with the women why they're killing the
kids in school while they're killing
their peers in school but for in this
case it was kids killing kids and the
challenge with that is that the kids
then the white middle class boys were
not getting the help that they need and
interestingly enough white middle class
boys are the number one purchasers of
rap music and when asked why they say
because they relate to feeling isolated
or not connected um and so again these
kind of highlight and speak to uh this
invisible nature of when we talk about
these categories the ones that are most
valued tend to be invisible so we talk
about black on black crime as if white
on white crime doesn't happen and the
reality is is that people tend to commit
crimes with people who look like them
because it's usually within their
neighborhood or people that they know
and so more than likely most cases um
across our country trends is that people
tend to commit crimes against people who
are typically the same race um as they
are or ethnic group so but but what
happens is that there's invisibility
that goes with that and therefore
assumptions that goes with that as well
so when we talk about this i always
wanted to highlight that when we talk
about stereotypes we talk about
uncharacteristics we all have it so it's
not like one group has it in the
redstone we all have it in all of those
dimensions that i just showed in the
previous slide and the reality is that
we're more likely to recall information
about people that we don't typically
have much exposure to and so those um
the recalling of those assumptions or
those perspectives are based as i said
before on media based on where we grew
up if we grew up in a neighborhood or a
community where we do not have much
diversity then as our our perceptions
around people are going to be based on
what we see on tv what we read in the
media and what people tell us about them
whether it be our friends and our family
and so therefore we're more likely to
recall that information when we see
people um people of diverse backgrounds
as well and when i say diversity i want
to be very clear here that people
oftentimes think diversity means latinx
et cetera diversity means everyone
because if you think about a crayola box
there's also a white crayon as well so
diversity if we're really going to talk
about the time of everyone as to the
diverse pool not just people of color or
underrepresented groups or terms that we
may use like that
um so i think that that's really
important to highlight as well and so
here when we talk about these
stereotypes it's almost like a white car
i just recently bought a white car i've
never noticed how many other white cars
are out there but now that it's in my
head because i have one i see white cars
everywhere and almost all the other cars
become invisible because i noticed the
white card so that's how these things
look um are perpetuated as well and so
we see it we hear it and so then when
because we hear that story when we see
someone um ask or respond in a certain
way we're going to pull back from those
things our resource if you will as a
video show the 11 million messages that
we get of which only 40 of them we can
actually truly process
so that being said then when we talk
about um these areas and we and we talk
about the disparities that we make that
exist as i just mentioned in the other
slide as it relates to oncology and
other areas we also then have to really
highlight some of the work that camera
jones and others have been highlighting
around the difference between equity
equality and justice and particularly
between equality and equity because
equality and equity is that when we look
at these stereotypes when we look at
these experiences and these poor health
outcomes um along the lines of
socio-economic status along this lines
of race uh rural urban uh um lgbtqa
populations all in all of these areas we
tend to find that people
who are in rural communities people who
are sex and gender minorities people who
are underrepresented race and ethnic
groups and women
and other gender groups most certainly
experience worse outcomes as it relates
to cancer and other chronic diseases as
well and the goal is that people often
think about in the 60s that we want to
focus on equality right well equality
means that as you see in this picture
everyone gets a stool and it but not
everyone still gets to realize the goal
which is to actually um participate
fully in in this journey called life if
you will um equity is a little different
what equity does is really kind of
creates and recognizes that there are
systemic challenges and barriers that
impacts people not being able to
participate in clinical research in
trials and also ensuring that they have
the best health outcomes um from
prevention all the way to survivorship
and even end-of-life care and so when we
look at equity we actually
implement these different resources or
tools if you will to be able to ensure
that people get to um
live out their best optimal life or
their best optimal opportunities as it
relates to her um to care now the
reality is is that when we look at this
we typically use this as resources like
things that we need to do to provide
access to good quality care right and so
if people need two stools to do that we
give them the two stools if they need
one they get one and that's kind of how
equity the framing of equity is but i'd
actually kind of start to think about
equity a little bit more different um
and as you can see here injustice is
that everyone actually gets to see
regardless of who they are in fact the
more recent pictures of this they have
taken out defense completeness once you
remove the fence then you've actually
removed all the systemic and structural
barriers that impact people um being
able to have full access to care whether
they live in a rural community whether
they're a race and ethnic or gender
minority or whether or not they are um
having living with poverty
so i really want us to think about
equity in a very different way um and
that's how we can start to really think
about how we view if you will um uh the
opportunity to increase diversity in
clinical research and trials so um i
often liken this whole idea of those
stools to more of a marathon and so if
you think about a marathon and if you
guys can just join me on this journey
for a quick moment here you think about
a marathon we're all standing we're
ready to go and just as we're ready to
go we let the gun go bam
and the person who shoots the gun goes
bam white men start running
keep running
keep running
keep running
all right 100 years bam white women
start running
keep running
keep running
keep running
150 years more bam batman start running
keep running
keep running
keep running
so now we're at 400 years bam black
women start running
keep running eat running
so when you think about this marathon
and everyone running this race if you
will what happens is that as you start
the race if you're starting at the front
you're going to create systems and back
in back then created systems the
education system they created the
criminal justice system they created
even the institutions of religion they
created um uh um education criminal
justice health care systems and who gets
access
finances in the financial industry all
of these things are created so that even
as white women start running they have
to start jumping over obstacles because
some of those things were not created
with them in mind or created with them
was intended for them to be able to
thrive in that space the same thing
happens when you think about every other
race and ethnic group and every other
disadvantage group economically uh
financially or sexual gender minority as
they continue to run this race if you
will you'll continue to see that the
obstacles are there because they were
not the systems were not intended for
them to be able to succeed if you will
and also not only do the systems that
work in favor of those who create it but
there's also they benefit from it
multi-generational right so the wealth
etc gets passed forward and forward and
so when we talk about equity we're
talking about trying to close those gaps
and those gaps are pretty significant
and that means that those gaps play out
in every area of our lives including
increasing including diversity in our
research and clinical trials recognizing
that most of our studies in the past
have mostly included white male and then
over time now we still see more white
male and females in clinical research
and trials but we still see this growth
on the representation that covert
highlighted significantly of
underrepresented race and ethnic groups
as well as other underrepresented groups
involved people in rural communities not
having access to clinical trials that
could actually be been significantly
beneficial to them
so when we talk about equity we're
talking about equity from that
standpoint where we're really wanting to
actually work toward being a part of
changing that and being equity
ambassadors if you will as providers in
in the clinic and so here this is just
another example of when we look at the
diversity in clinical research and
trials we know most certainly here we
have um race and ethnic groups most
certainly are least represented in 10
percent less than 10
are represented in our clinical trials
the same is true for oncology whereas
almost um less than two two to two to
nine percent of underrepresented groups
are actually involved in clinical trials
i'm sorry two to five percent nine
percent total are actually involved in
oncology trials and so again highlights
the fact that we have a significant
problem a lot of work to do and the
question is why do we see such diverse
such lack of participation we know many
of those reasons are related to policies
that now we know in january 2022 uh new
policies are coming into place during
this expand medicaid in such a way that
a patient can now receive standard of
care that will be paid by medicaid and
be on the clinical trial that was not
the case before so that's a huge win for
us there's other policies that are
currently being drafted in congress that
we've been a part of toward actually
increasing opportunities for more
diversity in our trials we also know
that we don't have enough diversity in
our workforce and then our research
teams and that plays a part our research
teams need to mirror those who look like
us who look like our community and the
patients that we serve and being
intentional about that is really
important we also know that many of our
studies our consent forms etc are not
available in other languages and so if
you don't speak english um you you have
a less chat less chance of being able to
participate in a clinical trial that
could actually improve your quality of
life potentially even save your life or
at least the life of others down the
line
we also know that in terms of
where clinical trials are available
typically tend to be around more
academic health centers and not
necessarily in some of our
community-based clinics and most
certainly not in our rural communities
and so these are some of the key
barriers that play a part in lack of
diversity in trials
we also know historically that there has
been a lot of medical atrocities that
happen both historic and current that
has impacted particularly people of
color and other underrepresented groups
as well in being able to trust research
and it's not so much that they don't
trust it as much as that research and
our health care systems have not truly
been trustworthy enough to be able to
make people want to actually build trust
and so it's a big work that we're doing
now to really stop building that
trustworthiness to actually help to
improve both access to head care access
to quality care and access to clinical
research and trials um it's also that
people are these broader systems that i
mentioned in a marathon plays a key part
in that as well and so we can't ignore
that people are not just living within
our bubble of our cancer world they're
living in a broader society that has not
necessarily always been um open to uh
the diverse populations and perspectives
that people bring and so most certainly
it plays a part in terms of how they
engage um with the system there's also
lack of information that goes out into
the community one of my big things is
that people in our communities need to
hear about clinical trials and research
before they ever hear the words you've
got cancer so the women here when and if
they hear the words you've got cancer or
their family member hears it then they
hear this possibly a clinical trial for
you it's not the first time that they're
hearing about it they're knowing about
it and getting more knowledge around
that so how do we engage our communities
in a way that we can be proactive in
that space i've mentioned the system
barriers already and as i mentioned
already there's some challenges
associated with the opportunities for us
to really create a more trustworthy
environment in our health systems and in
our cancer center
so why is this important the reality is
is that if we're going to really use
this framework of equity and ensuring
that everyone has access to your studies
and our clinical research and trials and
this includes biospecimen and biobanking
donation as well
that in order for us to really do great
research we need to make sure that we're
producing rigorous science and as the
nih actually has highlighted and
continues to highlight that the data
that we have and the data that we are
all using in our oncology studies and
researches and research across the board
is just too white and it is not allowing
us to be able to make the
generalizations that we should be making
and should be able to make we're not
able to do and fully explore differences
between race and ancestry which we know
that those two are very different
concepts and distribution related to
your genetic kind of ancestry and makeup
race being a social contract but it's
actually based on political terminology
so race changes as we go through our
lives
from being black to negro to color um
all changes at one point used to be
black white yellow red was the way in
which our races were described so race
is very much so politicized and very
much so a social product and construct
versus genetic genetics and ancestry and
there's also some research coming out
now in oncology that's showing that you
actually see different outcomes and
different um different outcomes when you
use race versus when you use ancestry
looking at health outcomes and so again
really
making sure that we can explore those
differences requires a diverse pool of
participants and by end biosamples by
specimens it's also important for us to
improve outcomes and reduce disparities
and also as i mentioned before it allows
us to produce equitable care
so the question here is that why are
people of color not participating in
clinical trials the study has always
been and the argument has always been
because they don't trust the systems
they don't trust health care well in
fact with the number of studies are
coming out now mine on some with reagan
durant um some with my partners both at
ucsf and at roswell we're all learning
and realizing through our research that
actually it's not so much that people of
color do not want to participate in
research in clinical trials as much as
that they're not engaged and they're not
being asked um and when and there's a
case study that actually came out here
but also known it in my study here
factors associated with participation uh
bias and stereotyping and unexpected
findings so more and more studies are
showing that people actually do want to
participate they just want to have a
conversation they want to learn more so
that they can be able to make an
informed decision just like we do with
any other health care decision making
process um also we found in a study that
was actually done by reagan durant
leaders principal investigators research
coordinators and teams but they found
that they bias and stereotyping was a
key part of the impact in their
perspectives around minority recruitment
in oncology trials and this study is an
important one because it really
highlights and documents what we know
exists in clinical care why would we
think it doesn't actually happen in
clinical trials as well in oncology uh
in this study this study actually
started to change the narrative because
in this case the uh research teams
actually in qualitative interviews
talked about the um that they saw
minority participants were perceived as
being challenging to work with or chat
or a challenge to deal with so they
oftentimes just don't ask them to
participate as some of the research
teams pi said that they're not perceived
to be ideal study candidates um and and
so on when asked or probe why there was
not much clarity around that we also see
that their providers were withholding
clinical trial opportunities from them
uh potential minority participants are
underrepresented race and ethnic groups
because they were thinking the clinical
barriers or other factors might be a
problem and this is before they actually
look at fully the person's full profile
or even talking to the patient about it
so we know then um in many studies is
that the reason number one reason why
most people participate in clinical
research and trials is because they were
asked they were informed and the number
one reason why most people don't
participate they had no idea that
clinical trials could even be something
that they could explore even if they
know that they may not qualify for it
would have been great for them to
actually know about it um and again this
gives us the opportunity to start
thinking about how do we act and how do
we engage our communities and our
patients more in clinical research and
trials and so now i'm going to go
through a few quick examples of how
we've been able to do that
and and then highlighting again that the
lens that we see in the world often
shapes how we interact how we frame our
research our policies and how we even
practice medicine
so this is a study here that we did um a
quick short version of this is that
basically i partnered with the river
church uh one of our researchers dr
mayor eppley focuses on h pylori as we
know this is the bacteria that are when
you have h pylori infection causes
stomach cancer we work together with the
church for a year and after a year the
bishop actually says why don't we bring
a clinical research study to our church
and so we actually opened up a clinical
study where we did blood draws the urea
breath test the questionnaire um to
really explore um ice color infection 25
of the 92 people that participated in
this midweek service event um actually
had h pylori infection in which we were
able to navigate them to a pcp and and
we had 80 cure rate over a six month
period because we lost two people to uh
follow up but again six people um again
highlighting where we're both me
addressing a need but we're also
creating opportunities where we're
bringing clinical research out into our
communities and going beyond those doors
another great example uh is what we have
here which is um uh equal acp this is a
a study looking at advanced care
planning
among race and that makers particularly
between blacks and whites actually and
what we know that there's a sharp
difference between black and white
populations in terms of who's actually
having advanced care planning and we
know advanced care planning improves the
communication improves people getting
what they need and what they want and
their values followed and ultimately
getting what they need at the end of
life if that is the case and so advanced
care planning is really critical to that
so we have five um 10 clinics across
five states 800 adults half black half
white so we're actually recruiting for
this study it's a five-year study and
they're being followed to see how we can
actually engage community health workers
in this space over this clinical trial
we're testing two different methods of
doing advanced care planning um
one that is more intensive the other one
is more um self-guided and we're looking
to see are there differences if you have
a black provider a black um
community health worker who is actually
helping to do the advanced care planning
program if we have race concordant
discordance if we have black a black
patient with um uh a black uh person
helping them with the advanced care
planning uh
do we see differences in the likelihood
to actually do advanced care planning or
not and we do the same for white so this
these questions are really important but
we're doing a strong stakeholder
engagement process we're actually
engaging stakeholders at each of the
sites instead of having one advisory
group we actually have one community
advice um several five of them at each
of the sites and at their clinics so
that we can really recognize the nuances
that are happening at the local level
this is another way in which we were
actually able to engage um and i will
mention from that last study as well is
that there was a point where we're
recruiting more um
white patients compared to black and so
what we ended up doing is slowing down
to looking at what the challenges were
and we actually made the modification so
we constantly in every meeting talk
about the recruitment strategy and this
should be consistent whether or not this
is a health disparity study or not this
is another study that actually was
really um four studies that actually are
within prostate cancer for metastatic
disease uh i actually work very closely
with dan george here at duke and as with
the abbey race study in particular
i know
really um american and caucasian men or
or white men and what we found in this
process is that we were actually
recruiting more white men than
african-american so we actually stopped
and slowed down and brought in made more
intentional efforts to recruit
african-american men to the just mass
program through the program and the
training we were actually able to meet
the goals and end on time what was
really incredible folks in abbyy race
and then we see now with these three
other studies in that in each of these
trials with either hormone therapy
chemotherapy or cellular therapy
african-american men entered the trial
with worse disease but response
responded better than therapy if we were
not doing these race stratified studies
and we were not making sure that we had
the right representation we would never
know these types of findings and it
makes us wonder what are the things that
we're missing in our studies when we're
not being intentional about engaging
diverse populations in our clinical
research and studies
so these are some key strategies that
we've implemented through that we did
the just ask program and all the ones
that i've mentioned we also ensure that
we work toward making sure that we're
being intentional in meeting our goals
around the diversity of um enrollment of
women and african-american latinx
populations and in each of these studies
we're being successful because we're
actually making it a part of every
meeting that we have
we also focus here on some other
strategies where we actually reach out
to our community and our patients who
are on their studies and so we both do
community assessments we engage our
community partners and so oftentimes our
community actually makes referrals for
patients because they know um it's where
we're becoming more trusted and they
know where they can actually get the
kind of care that they need if they hear
the words you've got cancer um we also
work with um latinx populations to
actually develop our can help us develop
our consent forms our recruitment
materials so that it can actually be
available in spanish as well uh we're
also doing the same now to read some of
our chinese populations in our area um
again really highlighting opportunities
to make sure our materials are um are
critical
so as a final step here um this is some
of the key things i always say and it's
always important for all of us that are
doing work in this space that a
recruitment and retention strategy in
clinical trials without a diversity plan
and a budget that corresponds with it is
not a recruitment and retention strategy
unless we're being intentional in that
space we have missed the mark on that
side blind spot by thinking having a
recruitment and retention plan and and
identifying the number of people that we
need on each of the categories for table
four is enough we have a lot more work
to do in that space and being
intentional with our teams makes a huge
difference um making sure we're just in
the language barriers and compensation
in that space making sure as i mentioned
before monitoring your studies so that
you know when to slow down so you can
make sure that you reach your goal and
you will reach your goal on time if
you're being intentional with it and
getting the right using the right
strategies having community and state
and patient stakeholders on our studies
are have been incredibly important and
we encourage all of you to think about
that if that's something you're not
doing now and to also develop patient
advisory counselors in that space it's
also important to make sure that we're
talking about implicit bias and how that
may be impacting some of the work that
we're doing and identifying
opportunities in that space as well we
also ensure and encourage our clinics to
engage as critical partners our
community and engage our community
clinics the a triple c association for
community cancer centers and asco have
done an incredible job in really pushing
us forward and engaging community
clinics as partners and our increase in
diversity so we're reaching the rural
communities we're reaching urban
communities we're reaching people who
are poor we're reaching the diversity of
race and ethnicity as well and then
there's also importance of increasing
diversity of our workforce what does our
research staff look like do they look
like us or do they look like our patient
population it's important for us to
ensure that that happens so that we can
make sure that our patients as they
engage with our system and engage with
that care but they also are fully aware
of um seeing people that look like them
uh in the community and in the um in
providing care
the last few things here really related
more to the one-on-one encounter with
that patient uh patients actually say
that they would rather providers and
research coordinators speak to them more
in terms of a conversation versus a
transaction so sometimes participating
in a clinical trial or asking to
participate can oftentimes be presented
as a transaction versus a conversation
that means thinking about how our tone
is what we're saying i'm incorporating
the why why you're asking them to be a
part of that study and how it can be up
how they can be a partner instead of a
subject in a clinical research study to
actually help advance science and lead
toward a cure so those are the
conversations of the community and our
patients that they want to hear even if
they know it may not be beneficial to
them being able to hear that they are a
partner with researchers with science
toward addressing um um these issues is
critical to them and important and it's
more of a conversation and then feeling
like it's a transaction and engagement
um these other points that are
highlighted is really ensuring that
we're consistently doing the work that
we do need to do to address the needs
and last but not least i'll invite
everyone to look at the implicit
association test that's actually um on
harvard's website and here's the site
here there's also a video called the
just ask video feel free to watch that
as well both of these will help to help
us to look recognize where our blind
spots are so that we can provide the
best care to our patients and invite the
diverse populations our diverse
populations to participate in our
studies by being culturally responsive
sensitive but also doing the work that
we need to do to be able to be effective
in addressing those kidney care
and that being said
thank you all so much for your time
thanks for being a part of this session
and again thanks to all the planning
committee for inviting me and really
hoping that as you here today and you
think about these studies and these
strategies that you can apply them in
your own uh backyard in your own work so
that we can be able to move forward
thank you so much
have a great day and i think i'll pass
it back to you christina
all righty
thank you dr barry
presentation we'll now start the q a
portion of the webinar if you do have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
look at it on the far left of your
screen
let's get started
our first question is how can i get
started incorporating stakeholders in my
research
that's a great question um there's
multiple ways in which you can do it but
i think one of the key parts is first if
you're part of an academic health center
to connect with your cancer center
outreach group as well as practice
engaging with your um clinical
translation science institutes as well
ctsas that may be there if not it's
still important for us to identify who
are the stakeholders in our community
there's a lot of community coalitions
that meet their faith organizations in
their community and work together to
identify who are some of those leaders
at least five or six of them bring them
together get their insights and input
and then develop an advisory council and
then that kill patients so if you think
about your patients both as
participating in trials some of your
patients who participate in clinical
trials could be some of the best
ambassadors that you could possibly have
and so they are ambassadors in the
community to talk to the community where
we actually have sessions where our
research teams um or our clinicians
we'll actually go out in the community
with a patient and talk about what it
means to be in a clinical trial we've
removed that now due to coving onto the
zoom platform and it's been incredibly
effective effective we have about 100
people sometimes that show up on these
sessions just wanting to hear and learn
more about clinical trials and covert
has brought that even more to the front
fat forefront but those are some of the
key steps that i would take
to move forward in that developing
advisory council and moving from there
thank you for that
we
also have one more comment
um this is greatly seen in south africa
people just assume all people are
african however there are many different
cultures in south africa and all with
different genetics
that was from the audience and
that was a fantastic point and it's a
huge point that i think you know we were
talking about the u.s i would say that
our global studies as well are obviously
showing the same thing and so it's so
important for us to not make assumptions
even from a global standpoint right in
terms of when we say africa everyone
thinks black um and it's not quite so
much africa is quite diverse too so
thank you for that comment excellent
point
i was going to say that one hits home
for me because one of my very close
friends is is south african and people
always get confused because she's white
but
but do you have dr barrett any final
comments for our audience
uh no i just hope that as you all
continue to do the work and whether it
be by a specimen donation and
identifying people who can give their
samples for your basic science and
translational research
or if it's engaging our patients as
participants in our clinical trials i
really want to encourage you to think
about um the just ask program and other
types of programs that can really help
you to implement the appropriate
strategies but being intentional and
making sure that your recruitment and
retention plan has a diversity strategy
and if you don't have that identify
experts who can help you to be able to
um outline what that diversity strategy
is and what that budget is and it will
benefit all and we actually will be able
to contribute to our guests and health
disparities through our research so
thank you all so much
thank you again dr for your time today
and your important research before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until october of 2023
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event and until next time goodbye
you